the corona virus pandemic has
highlighted the importance of teachers
in this uncertain time only on CBS this
morning we're revealing the 2020
National Teacher of the Year this year's
finalists include Louisiana social
studies teacher Chris dear Ohio language
teacher Leila cubish Kansas preschool
teacher
Tabitha Ross Froy and Montana science
teacher Linda Ross and we are delighted
to announce that the 2020 National
Teacher of the Year is Tabitha Ross Pro
mrs. Tabitha as she is known to her
students runs a preschool program housed
in a retirement village the unique
learning environment is built on the
interaction between the children and the
grandparent Ayers will talk to Tabitha
Ross pray in a moment but first we spoke
with several people who've been touched
by her program was one of your favorite
things that you did in must have this
class
I think the favorite lesson of mine is
love that we get shown to us and that we
are able to show that she loved him she
respected him
[Music]
she just pours her heart and soul into
these little kiddos at home every day in
my students yards and even with their
Corona
individualized sensory bins because
that's all in their favorite part of the
class
she's what every teacher strives to be
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations what does it mean to you
to receive this honor thank you for
being with us oh thank you so much for
having me oh I am overwhelmed with joy
and hearing those clips for the first
time really brought tears to my eyes I I
love those people that I heard I
recognized all their voices and this is
just I am so honored to represent what's
best about education and all of the
incredible hard-working people that are
the educators in our country
well great teacher there's nothing more
important than a great teacher even a
good teacher but great teachers are
really special you are you you are the
first public preschool housed in a in a
Kansas nursing home can you talk to us
about what what this multi-generational
approach to teaching does for the kids
you know it is the most joyful
experience that you can imagine they
come into our classroom and not only do
they get love and connection from the
teachers and staff but they get it from
our grandmas and grandpas which is what
we call our volunteers the residents who
live there in the retirement village
they get read to one on one every single
day which I couldn't do alone before
they they are connected to people who
are older than them who have differing
abilities and it has built so much
empathy in their hearts that's something
I wanted to touch on because I know you
prioritize teaching empathy with your
kids and teaching them to understand
their own emotions absolutely I think
that social-emotional learning is one of
the most important thing
that we can offer our students in
preschool and at all ages it is
something that every person needs and
something that I plan to advocate for as
National Teacher of the Year hey miss
Tabitha part of the fun of watching you
was watching your face watching the kids
talk about you it was so sweet because
we could all tell that you were so
touched by it but I want to say this to
you my sister Linney is an elementary
school teacher and she says she has
never heard from more parents than then
she's hearing now I think everybody has
a greater appreciation for the work that
you do the work that all of you all do
so what is your advice to parents who
are really struggling trying to teach
their kids at home
my advice for them is to give yourself
some grace you are probably doing a lot
of educational things already in your
day teachers and staff at the school
understand that right now we're in an
emergency situation and you are doing
your best so you know take deep breaths
do it I would coach this the kids
through and remember the most important
thing that you can do with your students
and your kids is to connect with them
through meaningful play and activities
that they enjoy ask them open-ended
questions that extend their learning and
and make sure they have opportunities to
read oh ask open-ended questions I like
that and what are your thoughts about
going back to school in the fall listen
I'll bet you left class in March and
haven't been back and there's all sorts
of debate on to go back to school in the
fall what's gonna be the sign for you
that says yep I'm going back I really
trust in the health officials and I will
be listening for when it is safe to do
that the safety of my students and the
residents at come burn old village
that's my top priority always and so I
will continue to do what's best for them
and listen to our local health
organization on when we're ready to do
that
Tabitha we heard one of the parents say
that you pour your heart into into the
kids well what's one of the best lessons
you've learned from your students
recently in in the midst of this
pandemic I've learned that learning can
happen anywhere at any time a lot of
what I've done is one on one video calls
with my students and their families and
I have been on a tractor ride I have
seen a kid on a horse I've been jumping
on a bed I have been all around families
houses inside closets and we're doing
learning at that time kids are resilient
and they are ready and right for
learning and any environment can do that
not just within the four walls of the
classroom
well tabatha Russ bright
congratulations on being National
Teacher of the Year and thank you for
all you do